y
vale
yo nací en perú me críe en lima que es
una ciudad de cara al mar como ensenada
de hecho su mar muy parecido y uno de
los recuerdos más hermosos de mi
infancia es cuando me llevaban a la
playa y si estudié ciencias marinas a
eso me dedico en términos profesionales
pero en el fondo yo creo que muchos de
nosotros cuando nos acercamos al mar
sentimos esa inmensidad esa tranquilidad
y hoy en día entiendo esa ilusión de
permanencia de que siempre va a estar
ahí y de que siempre va a estar bien
sin embargo nosotros también estamos
escuchando las noticias sabemos que
hemos llegado a cambiar las condiciones
climáticas en nivel global que esto está
calentando los océanos los está haciendo
más ácidos y que está causando que estén
desplazándose las especies y degradando
se los ecosistemas sabemos que la
mayoría de las pesquerías están
sobreexplotadas y sabemos que hay muchas
especies que hemos llevado hasta la
extinción sabemos que hemos contaminado
los mares con fertilizantes con químicos
hasta con fármacos farmacológicos hasta
con químicos farmacológicos y eso yo no
se les usted dando como noticia porque
yo estudio ciencias del mar no
necesitamos un doctorado para que yo les
diga esto porque ustedes lo saben y lo
escuchan y lo leen
[Música]
ahora uno de los riesgos que enfrentan
los ecosistemas marinos son los derrames
de petróleo y esto es algo tremendamente
serio y uno de los mejores ejemplos de
esto lo vimos en el 2010 cuando explotó
la plataforma deepwater horizon que
estaba extrayendo petróleo del pozo
macondo en el norte del golfo de méjico
a 40 kilómetros de la costa de luisiana
esta explosión no solamente causó la
muerte de 11 personas y se lastimaron
docenas de personas que estaban
trabajando en la plataforma sino que
dispara un derrame de petróleo bajo
condiciones que nunca se habían visto
antes era un derrame que ocurría a 1500
metros de profundidad donde hay una
presión altísima donde las temperaturas
son muy frías y donde no sabemos bien
para dónde van las corrientes y cómo se
comporta el petróleo
el derrame fue tan grande 5 millones de
barriles en 87 días que se veía desde el
espacio esta foto que tengo aquí es del
espacio y el área que cubría la
extensión esté más amplia que cubrió
sobre el golfo de méxico era de 40 mil
kilómetros que es el tamaño del estado
de yucatán era absolutamente enorme en
las noticias que veíamos a los pelícanos
a los delfines a los manatíes las costas
la gente tratando de limpiar la costa de
luisiana de misisipí y alabama partes de
florida lo que no veíamos estaba abajo
en la superficie del mar todo ese
ecosistema que no lo vemos porque
nosotros como humanos básicamente
vivimos en la superficie donde hay por
ejemplo
corales de aguas profundas embarrados en
petróleo todo lo que es la fauna marina
que está asociada al fondo muerta
básicamente lo convertimos en un
desierto
las actividades económicas por supuesto
que también se afectaron para darles
solo un ejemplo aquí está en rojo lo que
se tuvo que cerrar a la pesca para
prevenir que la gente consuma productos
del mar que pudiesen estar contaminados
con petróleo un área absolutamente
enorme el golfo de méjico
se cerraron los restaurantes los hoteles
y todos los comercios que estaban
alrededor de toda esta región le podemos
poner números fríos a esto hay un
estudio reciente que indica que todo lo
que le cuesta o le costó a bp este
derrame suma a 145 mil millones de
dólares esto incluye multas litigios
resarcimiento económico de diferentes
sectores como los pescadores los
turisteros todos los que estaban dando
los servicios alrededor del golfo de
méjico las multas que le puso el
gobierno americano la investigación la
restauración y todos esos 145 mil
millones de dólares son la mitad del
presupuesto que se está estimando para
mexico el próximo año para ponerlo en
contexto
nos podríamos preguntar ok pues pasó en
eeuu bp pagó arreglaron los gringos sus
problemas no podría pasar esto que iba a
pasar en aguas mexicanas el golfo de
méxico está compartido por eeuu por
méxico y cuba es un mar interior que
está rodeado por tres países aunque el
derrame fue la zona norte del golfo de
méxico las corrientes marinas conectan a
estas regiones
en la superficie cerca a la superficie
digamos los primeros 500 mil metros el
agua entra por el canal de yucatán subió
hacia el norte da la vuelta y sale por
el estrecho de florida pero más es el
fondo el agua entra por el canal de
yucatán da la vuelta hacia el oeste
llega hacia la zona media hacia méxico
va a la sonda de campeche sube y vuelve
a salir entonces está conectado un
derrame que pasa en el norte puede
afectar este lo que está pasando en la
parte sur del golfo de méxico y por
supuesto eso era de preocupación para el
gobierno mexicano porque estaban
previendo que podía haber muchísimos
efectos muy fuertes a los ecosistemas
marinos
yo creo que una de las cosas para mí
como profesional en ciencias marinas más
impresionantes
ha sido el ver la respuesta mexicana
ante esta situación que fue decir
tenemos que hacer algo como país tenemos
que organizarnos tenemos que convocar a
diferentes instituciones que tienen esta
experiencia trabajando en esta región
sean académicas del gobierno en la que
sea para poder nosotros hacer una
evaluación propia de nuestros mares y
este poder decir hay o no hay petróleo
hay o no hay un ecosistema hay este
efecto en el ecosistema y eso es en
efecto lo que hicieron hubo una
coordinación por parte del instituto
nacional de ecología y cambio climático
y se convocaron instituciones y entre
varias hicimos una evaluación del golfo
de mexico para ver si es que había
efectos e impactos del derrame petrolero
esta es una foto del buque justo sierra
de la unam que me tocó
y en varios de estos monitoreos que
hicimos a partir del 2010 hasta el 2015
y fue una experiencia muy rica por
muchas razones para empezar nos tuvimos
que coordinar entre diferentes grupos de
trabajo y diferentes instituciones
los científicos somos un poquito como
los gatos cada 15 hace un poquito lo que
le da la gana y se clave en sus cosas
cuando queremos participamos y cuando no
estamos en otro rollo y aquí lo que
teníamos que hacer realmente era
coordinamos con un objetivo común en muy
poco tiempo y ser tremendamente
eficientes al hacerlo
este pocos tiempo después del derrame
hicimos un crucero oceanográfico se
juntaron diferentes grupos de trabajo
con diferentes especialidades que nunca
habíamos trabajado juntos nos tuvimos
que poner de acuerdo coordinar nos tuvo
que haber un compromiso institucional
sumamente importante para poder hacer
eso sea la institución nos respaldo así
como el país respaldó lo que tenía que
hacer en cuanto de evaluar sus éste los
posibles impactos que hubiese y
aprendimos muchas cosas en este esfuerzo
lo primero que aprendimos es que casi no
conocíamos los ecosistemas marinos
mexicanos especialmente los que están
alejados fuera de la costa y si no
sabíamos que había y como estaba el
ecosistema entonces como íbamos a decir
si había una vida un impacto como lo
diferenciamos de algo natural
inmediatamente claro que es ser un
problema enorme y no sólo en méxico fue
un problema enorme en eeuu con todos los
estudios y buques y gente que tienen
allá trabajando lo segundo que
aprendimos es que no podíamos trabajar
de manera aislada que teníamos que
trabajar de manera interdisciplinaria
qué quiere decir eso que el biólogo
tenía que hablar con el químico que
tenía que ver con el físico y si tenían
que buscar a entenderse entre ellos y
eso no es fácil pero había que hacerlo o
no había manera de entender lo que
estábamos haciendo de poder dar un
diagnóstico al gobierno mexicano y por
último quedó muy clara que había una
ausencia de monitoreo de los mares
mexicanos o sea nadie está viendo que
pasen los mares solamente a veces en la
costa civil nos va pero allá afuera
quién sabe en el momento que necesitamos
tener una idea que está pasando cuáles
son los impactos y cómo puede repercutir
eso no solamente los ecosistemas sino en
la pesca en el turismo en el transporte
en la extracción de hidrocarburos no
tenemos la información que necesitamos
ahora podríamos pensar que esto no puede
pasar en méxico pasó en eeuu es un
sector que por supuesto tiene controles
para tratar de evitar que haya derrames
pero les voy a decir dos cosas ya hubo
un derrame petrolero en méxico en el 79
en un derrame está zona de campeche en
el pozo y esto q no fundará me enorme 3
millones de barriles tres o cuatro meses
más tarde había petróleo en las costas
de texas
segundo méxico es un país petrolero por
historia y hoy en día hay 111 áreas
contractuales para la extracción la
exploración y extracción de petróleo en
méxico de las cuales 50 están en aguas
del golfo de méxico entonces si a yo
creo razón para pensar que pudiese pasar
algo como un derrame
para mí un derrame es un poquito como un
asteroide que le puede pegar al planeta
es poco probable pero si ocurre es
absolutamente catastrófico y tenemos que
pensar en esos términos lo mismo un
terremoto difícil de pronosticar pero te
preparas para un terremoto entonces cómo
te preparas para una cosa de esta
magnitud que pudiese llegar a ser
catastrófica es un problema grande que
requiere de muchísimo esfuerzo y grandes
soluciones y por encima de todo
muchísima previsión y preparación
para eso tenemos que trabajar de una
manera diferente y ese es parte de la
lección que nos llevamos de este proceso
de monitoreo tenemos que cambiar la
aproximación científica y los de
trabajar de manera individual en un
problema que puede ser muy interesante
que puede ser muy relevante para la
sociedad pero que no es suficiente que
una persona o un grupo pequeño trabaje
sino que tenemos que trabajar de una
manera mucho más integral con mucho más
personas involucradas con áreas de
conocimiento y por supuesto con
comunicación también con los sectores
involucrados también tenemos que dejar
de pensar en bueno vamos a ver qué fue
lo que pasó y empezar a pensar en qué
podría pasar si hubiese un derrame y el
contestar del punto de vista científico
que podría pasar es una pregunta
muchísimo más compleja que requiere de
un conocimiento muchísimo más profundo
de un sistema entonces es algo que
tenemos que trabajar desde muchos
ángulos e ir construyendo estas
capacidades científicas que no solamente
es el conocimiento las capacidades
científicas también abarcan
a la gente principalmente a la gente a
la gente que se forma a los estudiantes
a los investigadores a los jóvenes a la
infraestructura con que mido con que
hago con que voy toda esta parte la
tienes que fortalecer la parte
institucional también es sumamente
importante las instituciones tienen su
manera de funcionar eso no es típico
solamente del sector académico cualquier
institución tiene su manera de funcionar
pero si tú vas a trabajar en un grupo
grande si vas a coordinar redes entonces
tiene que haber una manera de empatar
estas maneras de trabajar para que todos
los puedan avanzar de una manera
estructurada y coordinada
hemos estado ha sido un experimento los
últimos años
los comparto como ejemplo en un
consorcio de investigación en el golfo
de mexico que está tratando a través de
la formación de una red de investigación
muy grande de producir información muy
sólida y robusta que permita tomar
decisiones sólidas y que permita evaluar
daños en caso de que llegase a ver un
derrame en aguas mexicanas
para esto no solamente ha trabajado un
montón de académicos sino que hemos
estado muy de cerca con el rector de la
política científica y tecnológica en el
país que es el consejo nacional de
ciencia y tecnología con la secretaría
de energía con pemex y con uno de los
fondos de financiamiento más grandes del
país que es el fondo hidrocarburos y en
este proceso de trabajar con ellos en un
objetivo común hemos hecho yo creo que
un avance muy importante en cómo podemos
hacer y cómo podemos atender los grandes
problemas que enfrentan los mares
mexicanos y por qué no otros problemas
nacionales de gran envergadura y lo más
importante es que estamos aprendiendo a
trabajar como una red como una red que
requiere de un montón de características
sumamente importantes y que no son
necesariamente sólo científicas requiere
de la construcción de la confianza
requiere de la comunicación requiere de
la coordinación requiere de gestión y
requiere de rendición de cuentas todo
esto
hace un sistema que puede atender una
problemática en particular cada quien de
nosotros como investigadores o
científicos estos estudiantes estamos
enfocados en un aspecto de todo esto
pero lo que hace que valga es que te
funcione toda esta red
yo creo que el mensaje principal que yo
me llevo de mi experiencia estos últimos
años de estar involucrada en un proyecto
que jamás pensé que iba a estar esté
trabajando es que si se puede abordar
grandes problemas problemas como un
derrame de petróleo como los efectos del
sarga son las cosas que están llegando
ahora a las costas del caribe mexicano
como los efectos del cambio climático
pero no es nomás desde la trinchera de
una persona es un proceso que involucra
a muchas personas y que además tiene que
estar relacionada con diferentes
sectores en nuestro caso el sector
hidrocarburos la sociedad misma porque
los valores que dan estos ecosistemas
son este súper importantes para la
sociedad desde el punto de vista de
recreativo regresando a esa niña de 8
años yo que iba al mar y sentía esa
permanencia el mar siempre va a estar
ahí y siempre va a estar bien entonces
yo sí les puedo dar una
reflexión final simplemente es que a
veces minimizamos el potencial de lo que
tenemos para hacer para resolver grandes
problemas y que yo me dado cuenta que si
se puede hacer lo importante del
componente humano de que aprendamos a
trabajar en grupo que no es fácil y de
los compromisos en todo nivel desde el
personal hasta los grupos de trabajo los
en las instituciones y por supuesto un
gobierno que diga esto es importante y
esto es un problema al que le queremos
apostar y en el que queremos invertir
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]